TWO THREE FOUR IT'S UP TO YOU.
I SAW GIVE US THIRTY SECONDS
AWAY FROM HIS BATES THIRTY
SECONDS. THIS WILL GO UP. IT IS
A GOOD PICTURE TAKE ANOTHER ONE
PLEASE YEAH ABOUT STANDING.
CASES THE BETTER MARKETS
. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GONNA CALL THIS IS
HEARING TO ORDER GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE. WE ONLY HAVE THREE
BILLS TO HEAR TODAY THAT ARE
MOVING THROUGH THE PROCESS LATE
WITH ROLE WAIVERS SINCE WE ARE
PASSED FISCAL DEADLINE THEY
WILL ALL BE ELIGIBLE FOR DO
PASSED MOTION WE'RE ALSO
SENDING THE FOLLOWING THREE
BILLS DIRECTLY TO THE FOR
PURSUANT TO SENATE RULE TWENTY
EIGHT POINT EIGHT AB ONE AB ONE
MAIENSCHEIN A. B. TWELVE NINETY
GLORIA IN AB TWELVE NINETY NINE
SALAS. ARE WE HAVE. MS BAUER
QUE HAN CONS HIS ME PRESENTING
FOR MISTER TAKING ON AB FIFTY
FOUR WE'VE BEEN TOLD THEM IS
PETRIE-NORRIS MAY TRY TO GET IT
HERE GET YOURS ARE GONNA DO THE
TANG BILL. FIRST AND SO PLEASE
TELL US ABOUT A LET'S DO A ROLL
CALL. PORTANTINO I'M HERE
PORTANTINO HERE BATES BATES
HERE BRADFORD. BRADFORD HERE TO
RAZA DORADO HERE HELL JONES MY
CASKEY HERE MY CASKEY HERE WE
HAVE A QUORUM SO WE'RE GONNA GO
RIGHT INTO AB FIFTY FOUR BY MR
TANG SO PLEASE TELL US ABOUT
CALIFORNIA BEVERAGE CONTAINER
RECYCLING ACT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN COLLEAGUES THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO RESET AB
FIFTY FOUR BEHALF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TING THE RECENT CLOSURE
OF TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FOUR
RECYCLING CENTERS HIGHLIGHTS
THE URGENCY FOR CALIFORNIA TO
ADDRESS ITS RECYCLING
CHALLENGES. THE REMAINING
LIKELY CENTERS ARE NOW IMPACTED
A LONG LINES IN IT ABLE TO SOME
CONSUMERS LOOKING TO GET THEIR
REDEMPTIONS AND MANY RURAL
AREAS IN THE STATES HAVE BEEN
LEFT UNSERVED AB FIFTY FOUR
WOULD ADDRESS THESE NEEDS BY
FINDING MOBILE RECYCLING PILOTS
IN AREAS IMPACTED BY THESE
CLOSURES PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
FUNDS FOR EXISTING RECYCLING
CENTERS IN PROVIDING TEMPORARY
RELIEF DOORS THAT ARE
UNPREPARED TO PROVIDE REDUCTION
TO CONSUMERS. I HAVE WITNESSES
HERE IN SUPPORT MR ERIN MARINO
FROM THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION. AND I WILL TURN IT
OVER TO HIM. PLEASE SHARE.
THANK YOU A FOR A LONG DISTANCE
BILL WE STRONG SUPPORT. AB
FIFTY FOUR WE THINK IT WOULD
HELP TO DEAL WITH THE RECENT
UNEXPECTED CLOSURES OF A- LARGE
AMOUNT OF RECYCLING CENTERS
AROUND THE STATE. AS A VERY
TEMPORARY FIX AS WE AGREED UPON
AND SANITY Q. WE'RE GONNA COME
BACK NEXT YEAR TO WORK WITH ALL
THE STAKEHOLDERS TO. HOPEFULLY
FINGERS CROSSED FAMILY FIND A
SOLUTION TO HAVE TO DEAL WITH
CRB PROGRAMS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
SO WITH THAT WE- STRONGLY OR
DRIVE OUT. OTHER OTHERS IN
SUPPORT. MESSAGE MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS CHRISTMAS KAYLEE ON
BEHALF OF NIAGARA BOTTLING ALSO
IN SUPPORT. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
TONY GONZALEZ HERE ON BEHALF OF
TOM RUN NORTH AMERICA IN STRONG
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY POLIO
SHUDDER AND THREE ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY AND COUNTY SAN VERSUS
GOING STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
FOR OPPOSITION. IS THERE FILE
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS GILLIAN THERE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I WOULD
NOT THAT WE DON'T CURRENTLY
HAVE AN APPROVED POSITION ON
THIS WOULD WANTED TO KNOW THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION IS COMMITTED
TO THE CONVENIENCE GOALS
ESTABLISHED FOR THE BEVERAGE
CONTAINER RECYCLING PROGRAM.
THIS BILL PROPRIOCEPTIVE A
TOTAL OF TEN MILLION DOLLARS
ONE TIME FROM THE BEVERAGE
CONTAINER RECYCLING FUND OF
WHICH FIVE BILLION DOLLARS TO
SUPPORT RECYCLING PILOT
PROJECTS AND PROVIDED CERTAIN
CONDITIONS ARE MET. UP TO FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR SOME
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS TO LOW
VOLUME RECYCLERS. WE WOULD KNOW
THAT THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET
ACT INCLUDED TWO HUNDRED
SIXTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY UNTIL JANUARY JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO. OF FOR
CAL RECYCLE TO IMPLEMENT THE
RECYCLING PILOT PROJECT PROGRAM
BUT DID NOT PROVIDE FUNDING TO
SUPPORT THE RECYCLING PILOT
PROJECTS. LASTLY I WOULD NOTE
THAT THIS BILL MAY RESULT IN A
REDUCTION REVENUE FOR THE
BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING
FUND. THE LEVEL OF WHICH IS
CURRENTLY UNKNOWN. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MANY QUESTIONS. GO
AHEAD. IF YOU COULD. IN TERMS
OF THE INDUSTRY AND TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THIS SO THE OF THE
GROCERIES ARE ALSO DEALERS THE
GROCERY STORES CURRENTLY IS
THAT YOU'RE ASKING IS CURRENTLY
YES IN ORDER TO MAKE SENATOR
OSTERMAN ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
GROCERS GET THE WAY THE BILL
WILL AT THE REGIONAL BOTTLE
BILL WAS DRAFTED BACK IN THE
EIGHTIES IS THAT IT CREATED
HALF MILE CONVENIENCE OWNS AND
THE GROCERY STORES WERE MEANT
TO BE THE CENTER OF THE
CONVENIENCE ON BUT ANYBODY WHO
SELLS BEVERAGES. THAT DOES A
GROSS OF OVER I'VE OF TOP
MANNING IS TOO MANY DOLLARS A
YEAR THEY ARE ALSO SUBJECT TO
BE RESPONSIBLE FOR A PROVIDING
FOR OR HAVING A RECYCLER WITHIN
THE COMEDIANS ON AND BABSON
RECYCLER TO COLLECT BALLS.
OCCASIONS INSIDE THEIR DOOR
PANEL DOLLARS A DAY. SO THE
GROCERY STORES WOULD. NOT WOULD
BE EXEMPT FROM PAYING THE
REDEMPTION HERE SO WHAT THIS
BILL WOULD ONLY ADDRESS IS
THERE WAS A RECENT CLOSURE OF
RE PLANET RECYCLING CENTERS AND
THOSE AFFECTED ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED LOCATIONS SO AS OF NOW
THOSE THREE HUNDRED LOCATIONS
ANY GROCERY STORE ANY OTHER
DEALER BE SUBJECT TO A HUNDRED
DOLLARS A DAY OR IN STORE TAKE
BACK WHAT THIS BILL WOULD DO IS
ONLY ADDRESS THE RECENT CLOSURE
EVERY PLANET SO THOSE STORES
ARE ONLY AFFECTED BY THE AUGUST
FIRST ANNOUNCEMENT. WOULD HAVE
AN EXEMPTION UNTIL MARCH OF
NEXT YEAR FROM HAVING TO
COLLECT THE BOTTLES AND CANS
INSIDE THE STORE OR TO PAY THE
HUNDRED WHILE HUNDRED DOLLARS
TODAY WHICH WOULD ALLOW FOR
STAKEHOLDERS TO COME BACK NEXT
YEAR WHICH THE ADMINISTRATION
AND BOTH HOUSES OF AGREED IS
WHAT THE PLAN IS GOING TO BE
TAKEN BACK TO LOOK AT THE
BOTTLE BILL AS A WHOLE TO
FIGURE. OUT WAYS THAT THAT IT
WORK. TWENTY TWENTY FIRST
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX WHEN THE
BILL WAS FIRST PASSED. IS THERE
MIGHT BE A QUESTION YEAH I GOT.
IS THERE MOTION MISTER VACANCY.
THANK YOU WOULD YOU LIKE TO
COLLAPSE SPEC FAST WHERE I'M AT
ALL RIGHT WITH THAT WILL CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO. HI
PORTANTINO I BATES BATES AYE
BRADFORD. BRADFORD I'D TO RAZA
DORADO AYE HILL JONES MY CASKEY
MY CASKET I. THE BILL HAS GOT
FIVE VOTES WE'RE GONNA KEEP AN
ON CALL WE WILL GO TO YOUR AB
TEN EIGHTY SIX MISS
PETRIE-NORRIS I SOFT SLEEK IN
WILSON SHE'S HERE WILL LET THEM
DO THEIR IS AND THEN WE'LL TO
YOURS. SO PLEASE TELL US ABOUT
EIGHT TEN EIGHTY SIX. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR TODAY CENTER
GLAZER AND I ARE HERE TO
PRESENT ON AB TWENTY SIX A BILL
THAT YOU HAVE ALL. HEARD BEFORE
IT'S A DISTRICT BILL AMENDED TO
BE CLEAR TO CLEAR UP THE
AMBIGUITY BY AUTHORIZING NOT
REQUIRING THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS TO SELL THE
ALAMEDA TEST EXPANSIONARY OF
THE CARNEGIE STATE. RECREATION
AREA IF THE SALE IS IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE PUBLIC. THIS
AREAS RICH IN BIOLOGICAL AND
CULTURAL HISTORY AND THE SALE
OF THE LAND WOULD PROVIDE
PROJECT PROTECTIONS AND ALLOW
ALL VISITORS TO ACCESS AND
ENJOY THE LAND. AS A BILL
STATES THE LAND SHALL NOT BE
SOLD FOR LESS THAN WHAT WAS
ORIGINALLY PAID. AND THE
PROCEEDS OF THE SALE SHALL GO
TO THE OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE
TRUST FUND ALSO I WANT TO NOTE
THAT THE BILL DOES NOT AFFECT
THE CURRENT CARNEGIE. PARK IT
IS IN ACTIVE USE AND WILL
REMAIN ACTIVE USE DESPITE WHAT
STATE PARKS DECIDES TO DO WITH
THIS PLANT. THE BILL ENJOYS
BROAD SUPPORT INCLUDING SIERRA
CLUB COUNTY OF ALAMEDA EAST BAY
WE- ARE DISTRICT THE SOCIETY OF
AMERICAN INDIANS AND OTHERS.
AND WILL TURN OVER SENATOR
GLAZERS CONSCIOUS TO THANK
ASSEMBLY WOMAN THAT FOR. HER
LEADERSHIP ON THIS AND
DASTARDLY CENTER Y. CASKEY. FOR
HIS HELP ON THIS HAPPY ANSWER
QUESTIONS. YEAH WITNESSES. GOOD
MORNING BRIAN DAWSON WITH ZERO
CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF OUR
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION I MEAN
FIVE SORRY HALF MILLION MEMBERS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA NOT
FIVE ON A MILLION WE HAVE A LOT
OF US HERE COULD LEADERS ARE
VOLUNTEERS IN THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY SINCE ABOUT THE WORKING
ON THIS FOR THE PAST TWENTY
YEARS AND WHILE BOTH THE
SENATOR AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF
SPOKE TO THE ECOLOGICAL VALUE
THAT THIS LAND HAS I JUST WANNA
KNOW THE FISCAL IMPACT THAT
THIS WOULD HAVE. CURRENTLY THE
LAND IS BEEN TIED UP IN
LITIGATION FOR THE PAST TWENTY
YEARS AND SINCE THE FIRST
ATTEMPT IN SO THE CITY HAS BEEN
PAYING THAT AND- THIS BILL
WOULD ALLOW THE. IT'S SO WITH
THAT I PROTECT THE ANSWER I
VOTE THANK YOU. SUPPORT MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MONICA MILLER
REPRESENT THE COUNTY ALAMEDA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MORNING MR
TURN SENATORS LUCAS FRERICHS
ABOUT THE NATURE CONSERVANCY IN
STRONG SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING
WAS ADJOURNMENT SENATORS I'LL
PUT IT ON THE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY
AS WELL AS ON ONE CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. SOP POSITION. THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE. MORE THAN
ONE. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE CAME SOMBART ON
BEHALF OF THE BAY TO CALIFORNIA
FOR RECYCLE USERS AND ACCOUNT
FOR MOTORCYCLE DEALERS
ASSOCIATION THIS BILL HAS BEEN
A PART OF SENATE BILL TWO FORTY
NINE AND ONE FIFTY NINE BY
SENATOR ALAN. AND THAT WAS OF
COURSE THE REASON TO CONTINUE
THE OFFROAD PROGRAM ON A
STATEWIDE BASIS AND THIS WAS
ONE PART OF THAT BILL AND AT
THE END WHEN WE ALL CAME TO
HAVE A COMPROMISE WE TOOK THIS
PORTION OF THE BILL OUT.
BECAUSE IT WAS A LOCAL ISSUE.
IT ISN'T JUST A LOCAL ISSUE
MAYBE THE LAND'S LOCALLY BUT
USERS FROM ALL OVER THE REGION
COME IN IN USES PARK. PEOPLE
FROM ALL OVER NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA COMMITTING USES
PARK. SO TO CALL THE LOCAL
ISSUES I THINK A LITTLE
OVERSTATED I WILL SAY ON A
FISCAL RACES BECAUSE THAT IS
THE ARGUMENT WE'RE HERE TO FOR
TODAY. IS A DECEPTION SECTION.
TWO SAYS THAT THE BUSINESS
SECTION TO SECTION TWO OF THE
BILL AND SECTION FIFTY NINETY
POINT FOUR TWO CALLS FOR THE
SALE OF THE LAND TO BE AT THE
PURCHASE PRICE THE PURCHASE
PRICE WAS THIRTY YEARS AGO. I
THAT WAS NINE MILLION DOLLARS I
THINK THE WAY THAT STATE LAND
IS DISPOSED OF SHOULD BE AT A
FAIR MARKET APPRAISAL RATE WHY
SHOULD THE OFFROAD FIND BE
DENIED THE MANY VETS AT THAT'S-
APPROPRIATE NINE MILLION
DOLLARS MILLION DOLLARS AS AN
BY THAT MUCH IN TODAY'S MARKET.
REASONABLE APPRAISAL WE'VE BEEN
TOLD IS BETWEEN TWENTY SEVEN
AND FORTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS.
SO IF THEY'RE GOING TO.
PURCHASE THIS LAND THEN THEY
SHOULD BE PAYING BACK TO THE
FIND OF THE OF THE CURRENT
PRICE OF THE LAND THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CAPITAL INTERPRETING THE OFF
ROAD VEHICLE LEGISLATIVE
COALITION HEADQUARTERED IN SAN
DIEGO UNFORTUNATELY WENT OVER
HER TO OPPOSE THIS BILL I AGREE
WITH THE COMMENTS THAT WERE
MADE EARLIER ABOUT THE
AGREEMENT THAT WE ALL MADE AND
SENATOR ALLEN'S BILL JUST A FEW
YEARS AGO. BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
THIS IS THE STATE PARTY AND
THIS IS A BAD PRECEDENT IF
THERE'S GOING TO BE SOME
ACCOMMODATION THEN IT NEEDS TO
BE PRESENTED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. AND BY STATE
PARKS AND THIS BILL HAS NO
RELIEF IN IT FOR THE DRIVERS
AND THE- OFF ROADERS IN THE
BILL THIS IS ALSO A BILL FROM A
PROCESS POINT OF VIEW THAT I
FIND VERY FRUSTRATING THIS IS
THE BILL. THAT MISTER. THAT WAS
PUT ON SUSPEND ITS IN HOUSE AND
THEN IT WAS LEFT ON SUSPENSE IN
THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE AND NOW WE ARE FOR
THE GOT AMEND. THAT TO ME IS A
KIND OF GOES AROUND THE PROCESS
AND IT CERTAINLY
DISENFRANCHISES THE MANY MANY
MANY DRIVERS WHO CAME UP.
DURING THE POLICY DISCUSSIONS
ON THIS BILL THIS YEAR. PRESS
THIS WEEK OF LEGISLATIVE
WITHOUT WEEKS VIRGIN NO VOTE
AND URGED THE ADMINISTRATION
AND PARKS TOM CONTINUES TO
EXPLORE THIS ISSUE FOR REMEDY
FOR ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE FINANCE. I
WOULD NOTE THAT THE FISCAL
IMPACT OF THIS BILL IS UNKNOWN
AT THIS TIME AS IT IS UNCLEAR
HOW MANY POTENTIAL BUYERS EXIST
AND WHAT PORTION OF THE ROUGHLY
THIRTY ONE HUNDRED ACRES WOULD
BE PURCHASED WOULD KNOW THAT
THE ALAMEDA TESLA EXPANSION
AREA WAS PURCHASED THROUGH A
SERIES OF TRANSACTIONS TOTALING
APPROXIMATELY NINE MILLION
DOLLARS WITH THE MOST RESPECT
TRANSACTION CONCLUDING ROUGHLY
TWENTY YEARS AGO. I'M SELLING
THE PROPERTY OF THE ORIGINAL
PURCHASE PRICE WOULD FEEL
CAPTURE ANY INCREASE IN THE
VALUE OF THE PROPERTY OVER TIME
WHICH WOULD RESULT IN
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT LOSS TO
THE STATE AS THE BILL INCLUDES
A RESTRICTION LIMITING THE SALE
OF THE PROPERTY TO AGENCIES AND
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS FOR USE
AS A PARK OR OTHER OKAY SPACE
PURPOSE IT IS ALSO UNLIKELY THE
TAIL PRICE OF THE PROPERTY
WOULD REACH FAIR MARKET VALUE.
A TO THE EXTENT PRETTY IS SOLD
THE PROCEEDS LET THE PORTION
USED TO REIMBURSE COSTS
INCURRED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES WILL BE
DEPOSITED IN THE HIGHWAY
VEHICLE TRUST FUND OF LASTLY
THE DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION ESTIMATES THE COST
OF HOLDING THE SERIES OF PUBLIC
THINGS. RUBBING THE BILL WOULD
COST APPROXIMATELY FORTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM. THANK
YOU. SO WHAT I'M OPPOSITION HAS
ASKED ME TO LOOK AT A PAGE. TWO
AND THREE PARAGRAPH OR SECTION
TWO AND AS I READ IT THE LAND
SHALL BE SOLD FOR NO LESS THAN
THE ORIGINAL PRICE. SO THE NINE
MILLION DOLLARS IS NOT DIG
CEILING. IT'S THE FLOOR IS THAT
THE AUTHORS UNDERSTANDING. AS
THANK YOU SENATOR Y. CASKEY M.
FOR THAT CLARIFICATION. THE
BILL MERELY SAYS THE LAND
SHOULD BE SOLD FOR NO LESS THAN
THE ORIGINAL PURCHASE PRICE AS
YOU POINTED OUT SO NINE MILLION
IS THEM. AND THEN THEY WILL GET
BUT THEY CAN ABSOLUTELY GET
MORE. I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT
THIS IS AN EXTREMELY RURAL PART
OF OUR DISTRICT THAT IS OWNED
IN A WAY THAT IS NOT AMENABLE
TO. DEVELOPMENT OR ANYTHING
THAT WOULD BRING IT TO THE
PURCHASE PRICE OF LAND
ELSEWHERE IN THE BAY AREA BUT-
THE BILL WOULD NOT STOP PARKS
FROM SELLING FOR MORE THAN THE
ORIGINAL PURCHASE. NOW ALSO I
THINK YOUR OPENING YOU TALKED
ABOUT THIS IS A MERE
AUTHORIZATION FOR TSG TO GO AND
SO THIS IS WE WOULD ANTICIPATE
THAT THERE WOULD BE.
NEGOTIATIONS ON THE ACTUAL
SALES PRICE IS THAT YOUR
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW THIS BILL
WOULD WORK. YES AND ALSO POINT
OUT THAT AND YOU KNOW THE
OPPOSITE AND- LOCAL ABOUT THE
AUTHORITY OF STATE PARKS IN OF
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THIS
BILL IS MERELY AN OPTION FOR
THEM TO STOP. WE ARE NOT.
MANDATING ANYTHING AND SO THEY
WERE TAKING THE AUTHORITY THAT.
THE OPPOSITION WOULD LIKE TO
SEE EVEN IF THIS BILL PASSES.
CURRENT LAW CURRENT. LAW IS A
TWO DAY ALLOWS WHEN THE STATE
IS DISPOSING OF EXCESS PROPERTY.
TO REACH OUT TO OTHER PUBLIC
AGENCIES THAT MIGHT BE. MIGHT
BE INTERESTED IN IT I JUST
HAPPEN IN MY DISTRICT WE- THE
AGNEW STATE HOSPITAL WHICH HAD.
WHICH WAS PURCHASED BY THE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND THE- CITY SAN JOSE
FOR RECREATIONAL PURPOSES. THE
STATE LAW CURRENTLY ALLOWS FOR
DISCOUNT IF THE PURCHASE THAT
IS GOING TO BE FOR PUBLIC USE.
AND THERE'S GONNA BE A
RECREATIONAL ELEMENT OR PARKS
ELEMENT IS THAT YOUR
UNDERSTANDING OF THE CURRENT
STATE LAW ALSO. JUST YOU
SENATOR AND I DON'T KNOW
SENATOR GLAZER KNOWS MORE ABOUT
THIS I'M NOT FAMILIAR WITH THAT
PART OF A LOT BUT- I MEAN THIS
WOULD NOT ALLOWED FOR. THIS
WOULD NOT ALLOW FOR TO BE SOLD
FOR LAST AND THE PURCHASE PRICE
OF THAT DISCOUNT WOULD. THERE'S
BEEN A FORTY TWO MILLION DOLLAR
FIGURE OUT HERE IN A NINE
MILLION DOLLAR FIGURE IN JUST
SO WE'RE ALL CERTAIN THAT THE
STATE LAW. ALLOWS WHEN YOU'RE
SELLING TO A PUBLIC ENTITY THAT
YOU CAN GIVE A DISCOUNT BECAUSE
OF THE DESIRABILITY WE HAVE AN
OPEN SPACE. UNFORTUNATELY IT
DOES NOT ALLOW FOR THE SAME
DESCRIPTORS JOB. DISTRICTS
BECAUSE WHEN IN OUR- EAGERNESS
TO BALANCE THE BUDGET IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE WE TOOK THAT
PROVISION OUT I KNOW WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO BALANCE. FOR FINANCE
HAVE A QUESTION MISTER CHAIR.
IS THE CURRENT LITIGATIONS.
TESTIMONY WAS A CURRENTLY THE
CATION IS COSTING THE STATE.
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS OR MONEY
EACH YEAR AND THAT THE KINKS
SAILOR CONCLUSION OF THE
RELEASE OF THIS PROPERTY WHICH
STOP THAT BLEEDING IS THAT YOUR
UNDERSTANDING ALSO. ACTUALLY I
WOULD HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU
ON THAT SENATOR WHICH IS IT
GETTING BACK TO THAT WHAT THE
ACTUAL AMOUNT HAS BEEN THAT
WE'VE SPENT OVER LAST TWENTY
YEARS IN LITIGATION OR THAT IT
WOULD NOT STOP. AS THE BULLS I
DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH WE SPENT TO
DATE ON MEDICATION AND WHETHER
OR NOT THAT WAS STOP AS OF.
THAT POINT THE USES OF THIS
WE'RE MEASURING THE FIFTH. TO
THE FIFTH. EIGHT WILL BE THAT
WOULD BE A COST THAT WE
WOULDN'T OCCUR ALTHOUGH. IT
SEEMS REASONABLE THAT SEVENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT THE STAFF
REPORT PUTS IN FOR THIS. YOU
KNOW. THE SALE OF PROPERTY
WHICH WOULD BE REIMBURSABLE
FROM THE VEHICLE FUND. SEEMS
NORMAL YES THAT IS THAT IS THE
USUAL PROCESS. THAT'S IT MISTER
NOW WITH THAT MOVE IT. I HAVE A
MOTION MISTER JONES HAD A
QUESTION I'M GOING TO MISS
BATES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND I'M PUSHING MISS RIGHT
COUNTY'S LAND QUESTIONI THINK
THOSE WERE YOU KNOW A REALLY
GOOD. BACK UP TO HAVE. I'VE
SPOKE ON THIS OR JUST WANTING.
LARGE AND MS LYNCH. KIND OF
SUMMARIZE MY. TURNS BEFORE BUT
NEW. AND MISS RIGHT COUNTY KIND
OF CAMP DONALD A TWO
DIMENSIONAL MORROW. MENTIONED
THE YOU KNOW THE POTENTIAL
SALES PRICE OF THIS. AND SO OF
COURSE I'M HOPING THAT IT
DOESN'T GET SOLD. BUT IF IT
DOES GO THROUGH THAT PROCESS.
YOU KNOW AS AN- ADVOCATE AND-
YES SOME IS SUPPOSED TO THE
IDEA ANYWAYS I'LL BE WATCHING
VERY CLOSELY TO MAKE SURE. HOW
THOSE NEGOTIATIONS GO AND- YOU
KNOW WHAT THE FINAL IF IT DOES
GET SOLD HOW THAT FINALLY
COMES. TO BE SO THANK MITCHELL
MARK FOR PUTTING THAT OUT. THIS
BATES I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THE
COMMENT REGARDING LITIGATION SO
THE LITIGATION DOESN'T GO AWAY
EVEN IF THE STATE DIVEST ITSELF
OF THE OWNERSHIP IS THAT
CORRECT. ACTUALLY I DON'T KNOW
THE ANSWER THAT QUESTION HAT
HAVE HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU ON
THAT BECAUSE THAT WOULD BE VERY
IMPORTANT I THINK IN TERMS OF
THE FUTURE OF THE PROPERTY AND
WHOMEVER WOULD ACQUIRE IT
THROUGH A PURCHASE THE SECOND
THING THAT TROUBLES ME OF
COURSE IS THE PROCESS WHICH WAS
BROUGHT OUT BECAUSE IT HASN'T
ALLOWED THOSE WHO HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH. THE MANNER IN
WHICH IS GOING FORWARD I TO
HAVE THEIR SAY SO I JUST WANT
TO PUT THAT ON THE RECORD AND
FINALLY ON IN OUR ANALYSIS
THERE IS A CONCERN ABOUT THEM
HAVING THERE'S NO REVERSION
CLAUSE WHICH MEANS THAT IF IT
WASN'T SOLD DATA IF IT WAS SOLD
THAT THERE WOULD BE A
PROHIBITION. OF FOR IT BEING
SOLD FROM THAT SECOND. JUST SIR
TO A SECOND PURCHASER. WHO
COULD THEN USE THAT FOR YOU
KNOW PRIVATE DEVELOPMENT AND IT
SOUNDS TO ME LIKE. YOU YOU
ADDRESS THAT KIND OF BY SAYING
IT SO RURAL THAT WOULD BE A
VERY. FAR STRETCH. THIS IS
GOING TO COME OUT THERE AND YOU
KNOW BUILDING. FOUR HUNDRED
UNIT. AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ANYWAY. BUT TO THOSE ARE
CONCERNS OF MINE SO I WILL NOT
BE ABLE TO SUPPORT IT TODAY BUT
I CERTAINLY I. WILL WATCH IT
CLOSELY GOING FORWARD BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
HAVE. CONSERVATION LANDS ON
THERE ARE PARTNERED WITH THOSE
THAT ARE VERY ACTIVE. BY THE
WAY WE HAVE A VERY DIFFICULT
SITUATION AND MY DISTRICT. IN
THE SOUTHERLY PART OF IT WHERE
WE HAVE EXACTLY THE SAME THING
AND CONSERVATION. A LARGE PIECE
OF PROPERTY THAT WAS CONSERVE.
OUR FOR ENVIRONMENTAL PURPOSES
MITIGATION PURPOSES AND ALSO
PARTNERED WITH. AN AREA THAT IS
FOR OFF ROADING AND WHAT'S
HAPPENED IS THERE'S BEEN A
DEGRADATION. OF THE
CONSERVATION PART BUT THERE'S
ALSO BEEN A ARE TRICKS AND- ON
THE PROMISES THAT WERE MADE ON
TO THOSE TWO. SO IT'S NOT AN
EASY IS NOT AN EASY
PARTNERSHIP. SO A LOT OF
THOUGHT HAS TO GO INTO THE WAY
IT'S DONE. SO WITHOUT. THANK
YOU FOR YOU KNOW COMING IN. I
WILL BE SUPPORTING IT TODAY BUT
AGAIN I WILL BE WATCHING GOING
FORWARD MISTER JOHNS AS A
FOLLOW UP YES I DO THINK MISTER
CHAIRMAN I THINK MISTER WHITE
CASKEY AND MS BATES HAVE DUG
INTO A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE. ON
THIS PARTICULAR MATTER
ESPECIALLY WITH THE COMMERCE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND I
WOULD AND IT'S IT SEEMS LIKE TO
ME I'M GETTING FROM DEPARTMENT
FINANCE THAT THEY WANT TO GET.
TO THE BOTTOM OF THIS AND GIVE
US THIS INFORMATION. I'M
WONDERING IF IT WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE FOR THE MOTION
MAKER TO WITHDRAW AS MOTION
TODAY AND WE HOLD THE BILL HERE
THERE'S NO CRISIS THE- AND
THERE'S NO IMPENDING EMERGENCY
ON THIS WE CAN WORK ON THIS
OVER THE TERM. AND MAYBE EVEN
SOME OF US THERE AND DO SOME.
VISITS OF THE OF THE PROPERTY
AND CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION
WHICH I THINK WOULD LEAD TO A
MORE POSITIVE DIALOGUE BETWEEN
THE PROPONENTS AND OPPONENTS OF
THIS PARTICULAR. TOPIC. I'M I'M
NOT CARE WITHDRAW MY MOTION.
ALTHOUGH I THINK THE YOUR
COMMENTS WOULD GO TO THE ACTUAL
COSTS BECAUSE OF FINANCE WOULD
GIVE AGAIN MORE ONLY
AUTHORIZING DSG SO THERE'D
FINANCES GET A FOLLOW UP
THEY'RE GOING TO GET. THIS IN
FOR THIS INFORMATION AND THAT
MAY AFFECT. A DEAL POINT I'M SO
I WILL NOT WITHDRAW MY MOTION
MISTER CHAIR OKAY NOW I WOULD
JUST COMMENT THAT. WE'RE NOT
MANDATING ANYTHING OTHER THAN
ALLOWING A CONVERSATION TO
CONTINUE. AND SO I THINK GIVEN
THAT FACT THAT THIS IS JUST.
FRANKLY AUTHORIZING PEOPLE O
TALK. I DON'T SEE THE NEED TO
HOLD COMMITTEE BECAUSE- WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE OUTCOME OF
THAT CONVERSATION THAT
DISUSSION. THE PRICES SAID AS
A MINIMUM NOT A MAXIMUM. TGS
STILL WILL APPROVE ANYTHING
THAT. WOULD WOULD BE
FORTHCOMING. SO I'M DOUBLE
PUTTING THE PEOPLE OUT BECAUSE
I THINK IT JUST ENCOURAGES A
CUT ALL THE RIGHT IS A CUT. IN
LIKE POST. THAT THAT WE
APPROVED A FEW YEARS AGO I WAS
PART OF THAT CONVERSATION
THERE'S NO CONFLICTS WITH. THIS
AUTHORIZATION THAT'S PROVIDED
HERE THEY REASON THE BILLS HERE
IS BECAUSE THE DEPARTMENT SAYS
THEY DON'T HAVE THE
AUTHORIZATION SO. IT RESOLVES
THAT THIRTY. SECONDLY FOR THE
OFF ROAD ENTHUSIASTS AND WE
HAVE MANY IN OUR DISTRICTS THAT
ENJOY THAT ACTIVITY THERE'S A
PARK RIGHT THERE NEXT DOOR THAT
THEY PARTICIPATE IN AT. AND
THAT NOTHING IN THIS BILL OR
ANY. POTENTIAL SALE OF THE
PROPERTY WOULD AFFECT. THE
ABILITY FOR THOSE WHO ENJOY
THAT ACTIVITY TO DO SO. IT'S
ONE OF EIGHT PARKS IN THE STATE
AND WE'RE PROUD TO HAVE IT HERE
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE A LITTLE
MORE RESPONSIBLE USE PERHAPS
BUT- IT'S CURRENTLY. USED
ALTHOUGH THERE IS DECLINING
DISSIPATION ACCORDING TO SIX.
AND FINALLY THE CONTROLLING
ELEMENT HERE IS THE DEPARTMENT
OF PARKS AND RACK WITH ADVICE
FROM THE COMMISSION OFF
HIGHWAY. VEHICLE COMMISSIONERS.
IN TWO YES THE SPORT INVOLVES
AND ALL THAT GOES ON. WITH THAT
ACTIVITY STATE SIR ON THIS
PROPERTY AND THE PROPOSAL TO
EXPAND PROPER. AND SO THEY
CONTINUE TO BE AN TROLL SIMPLY
DEALS WITH THE BLIND SPOT THAT
THE DEPARTMENT THEMSELVES OF
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS LITIGATION
GONE ON AND ON FOR YEARS AND
YEARS. THE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF BEING SPENT ON
SPECIAL. IN A SITUATION WHERE.
WE THINK THERE ARE OTHER
OPTIONS THAT THEY SHOULD THAT
BE A AVAIL TO IF THEY DECIDE
IT'S APPROPRIATE AND THAT'S THE
PROBLEM. WITH THAT APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT TODAY. WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ABBOTT ON
FOR WITH THAT WILL TAKE THE
ROLE. THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO I'D BATES. BRADFORD.
DORADO. TO RAZA AYE HILL HILL I
JONES JONES NO BY CASKEY BY
CASKEY AYE. BRADFORD AYE
BRADFORD AYE. BATES NOW. THE
BILL IS OUT FIVE TWO TWO. WE
WILL GO TO MS PETRIE-NORRIS AND
AB NINE TWENTY
. MS
PETRIE-NORRIS PLEASE TELL US
ABOUT AB NINE TWENTY GOOD
MORNING HI MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THE PURPOSE OF AB NINE
TWENTY IS TO PROTECT PATIENTS
WHO ARE IN RECOVERY FOR
SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT.
EIGHTY NINE TWENTY WILL REQUIRE
OUTPATIENT SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT PROGRAMS TO BE
LICENSED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES A
REQUIREMENT THAT WE DO NOT
CURRENTLY HAVE AND THAT I THINK
IS A THAT IS A HUGE GAP IN IN
OUR REGULATORY FRAMEWORK THE
CARD MINISTER THE PROGRAM. WILL
BE COVERED BY THE OUTPATIENT
PROGRAM. THE AMENDED BILL THAT
WE'RE PRESENTING TODAY PULLS
LANGUAGE FROM CENTER BILLS SB
THREE TWENTY FIVE WHICH WAS
PREVIOUSLY. I PRESENT TO THIS
COMMITTEE AND DIVE RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT I WOULD LIKE
TO THINK SENATOR HEALTH FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS REALLY
CRITICAL ISSUE. I'VE CENTER
HOLES THAT WILL CO AUTHOR FOR
THE SPELL AND DAD ALSO SENATOR
BASS WHO IS A CO AUTHOR FOR THE
SPELL. AND PLEASE HAVE TO
SUPPORTERS HERE WITH ME TO
TESTIFY WERE PLACE TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE. ON A SEPARATE COMMON MARK
BREANNA BEHALF OF SHATTERPROOF
FOR NATIONWIDE A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO THIS
ISSUE. AND WE JUST APPRECIATE
BOTH CENTER HILL AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD FOR US.
THIS BILL WOULD ASSURE THAT NOT
ONLY FOR THE PATIENTS WHO ARE
SEEKING TREATMENT BUT ALSO FOR
THEIR FAMILIES AS WELL AS THOSE
WHO PAY FOR THOSE TREATMENTS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE TREATMENT
THAT GOES ON IN THESE
FACILITIES IS APPROPRIATE. IS
SCIENCE BASED AND THEY'RE
GETTING THEIR THEIR MONEY'S
WORTH IN IT WILL HELP TO
ELIMINATE ANY OF THE-
SHENANIGANS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
HAPPENING WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
ROBERT HARRIS ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF ADDICTION
MEDICINE LONG. CO SPONSORS THE
BILL THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE DONE YEARS AGO LIKE
MOST STATES DID THAT CRITICAL
PART OF TREATMENT IS OUT
PATIENT AND IF YOU DON'T HAVE
CONTROL OVER WHO'S DOING IT AND
WHAT THEY'RE DOING BEN YOU HAVE
NO CONTROL AND YOU HAVE NO.
GOOD OUTCOMES PATIENT SO.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST HERE YES.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT. OUR REALTOR
MEMBERS SURE DAILY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF
ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS IN SUPPORT. BACON
ALL RIGHT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT. THEY TEN ON BEHALF OF
TWO ORGANIZATIONS A CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
AND THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. YOUR CHAIRMAN OF
MEMBERS HAULING MEASURE BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
ALCOHOL DRUG PROGRAM EXECUTIVES
IN SUPPORT AND WE JUST LIKE TO
MAKE A COMMENT THAT IN TERMS OF
DRAFTING THERE ARE SOME
REFERENCES TO SENTENTIAL THAT
SHOULD BE REMOVED AT SOME POINT
AND- IF NOT NOW THEN. NEXT YEAR
MAYBE THANK YOU. MR TURN MEMBER
BOB ZERO AND WE HAVE THE
NATIONAL UNION AND HEALTH CARE
WORKERS AND HE JUST TREATMENT
CENTERS IN SUPPORT. TIM LYNCH
ON BEHALF OF A BETTER LIFE
RECOVERY WHICH OWNS AND
OPERATES RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT
FACILITIES IN AN OUTPATIENT
TREATMENT FACILITY IN ORANGE
COUNTY THAT WOULD BE SUBJECT TO
LICENSURE UNDER THIS BILL AND
WE SUPPORT IT. FINANCE ALTHOUGH
THE NUMBER OF OUT PATIENT THAT
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT RECOVERY PROGRAMS IN.
LAND KNOWN A BASED ON THE EIGHT
HUNDRED THIRTY THREE
VOLUNTARILY CERTIFIED
OUTPATIENT PROGRAMS CURRENTLY
CERTIFIED. THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES ESTIMATES
IT WILL REQUIRE AT A MINIMUM
THIRTY POSITIONS AND FOUR POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND. IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AN ON
GOING. TO IMPLEMENT THIS BILL.
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO NOTE THAT
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT
ALTHOUGH THE BILL AUTHORIZES IT
TO CHARGE A FEE THAT DOESN'T
EXCEED REASONABLE REGULATORY
COSTS MINISTRY AND LICENSING.
THE BILL PROVIDES. US WITH
CHAPTER SEVEN POINT THREE OF
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY. WHICH
ONLY APPLIES TO CERTIFICATION
OF PROGRAMS RATHER THAN
LICENSING AND AS SUCH IT IS
UNCLEAR APARTMENT ACTIVITIES
CAN BE SUPPORTED BY FEES AND
ABSENT THIS HE REVENUE COSTS
WOULD BE BORNE BY THE GENERAL
FUND. THANK YOU. THE COMMONS
QUESTIONS. MR HELP EXERT
PRINCIPLE CO AUTHOR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND- WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
FOR HER HER STRONG STRONG
LEADERSHIP IN THIS FIELD AND
TRYING TO CREATE AND ESTABLISH
CREDIBILITY AND INTEGRITY
WITHIN AN INDUSTRY THAT IS
FRAUGHT WITH. WITH ABUSE AND
PAIN TO SO MANY PEOPLE TO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND I THINK THE
COST WILL BE RECOVERED THROUGH
THE FEES IN A IN A WAY THAT
WILL BRING THE GENERAL FUND
COSTS TO A MINIMUM. SO I
APPRECIATE THE CONSIDERATION OF
THE CHAIR IN THE COMMITTEE. AND
WOULD BE HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL.
CLOSE THANK YOU CHAIR AND THANK
YOU TO THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
YOUR HELP IN IN MOVING THIS
FORWARD AS I SAID AB NINE
TWENTY CELLS HAD IMPORTANT
REGULATORY GAP AND THAT WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. WHENEVER WE HAVE A
MOTION PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR DINO HI PORTANTINO
AYE BATES. BATES AYE BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE DORADO. DORADO AYE
HILL HILL AYE JONES JONES I
WIECKOWSKI. MY CASKEY I. THE
BILL IS OUT SEVEN ZERO OUR
FIRST BILL IS ON CALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
WELL IF THE CALL IN AB FIFTY
FOUR. MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR HILL. WELL I JONES
JONES I. THE BILL IS OUT SEVEN
ZERO THAT CONCLUDES OUR
BUSINESS THANK YOU EVERYBODY
FOR GREAT YEAR. WE'LL BE BACK
IN JANUARY